Let's start today with Vall from San
Diego. Hey, Val, what's going on?
Hi. How are you? How can I use
this, David? Yes, this is David.
Oh, wow, David.
So basically I have it kind
of easy question, because I'm actually getting
ready for work. OK, I don't want to keep you.
No, no, it's OK.
But also, if I talk too much,
I tend to confuse myself. So. OK, I'm going to
keep it short, please. So basically my my question
kind of came up to me when I was talking
to someone close to me and basically they
were talking about how they touched base with
someone from Amazon. Right. Can you hear me?
Well, I can. Yeah. Yeah, you
can go right into the question.
Even though basically the piece the that that
person was telling me how they talked to an Amazon
patient. Right. A customer service person, because
they wanted to have like a ten dollars shipping
refund. And they explained to me the whole process
of like how they chatted with the pricing and how
basically they were able to give him the refund
because he complained about the customer service.
And what I was very, very surprised and shocked
with was how. At such a low type of low, people
consider it a low level job, some people do, but
I consider customer service really important,
but basically some people. Basically, what I
thought was interesting was the fact that you can
actually track a whole conversation down to one
customer service representative, right. So they
are now accountable for what they said. Right.
And I was thinking literally, I think I told him
I was like, dude, wouldn't it be amazing if,
like, I could have that at my work so that I
know that I didn't say anything mean to a patient
so they could check it out. And if everyone had
that sense of accountability, like the people
who went into the capital, like it would be
so much easier. I don't understand how someone
from Amazon has to have way more accountability
than the people who actually broke into somebody's
place of work is essentially what happened?
Well, a lot of them are getting caught because
they ended up on camera and they ended up
recorded. But but you're making a good point,
which is that the default and part of this,
unfortunately, is because of surveillance.
Capitalism, as described by Shoshana Zubov,
who we talked about, I don't know that we should
be cheering about the level of of data collection
that you describe with Amazon, although certainly
they're going to have transcripts of customer
service. But how are we getting away without
more of it at the capital? And fortunately enough
people were recording things that people
are getting caught, arrested and charged.
Yes, exactly, but to me, what's shocking is
not shocking, but it's like interesting for
us to know how in America or the United
States of America how it's possible that
someone who has, like most of the time
an Amazon employee doesn't have this huge
education. You know, how is it possible
that someone with low education
probably is working just to make ends meet?
You know, someone like that, how can they be
have way more responsibility and get in more
trouble than some people, you know, like that?
Yes, I think you're absolutely right. Well, there
are definitely some inconsistencies there in terms
of in terms of accountability. Well, I appreciate
the call. I hope to hear from you again.
Why don't we go next to Eric from
Texas. Eric, you're on the air.
Hello, can you hear me? Yes, I can.
All right, so I want no part of me.
As a new generation enters politics, what
would they bring to the political sphere?
I I don't know, I mean, that's that's up to them,
right? That's a hard question to answer. I mean,
I think the can. Can you say more? I
don't I don't know. I'm not I'm not sure.
I don't know what generation you're referring
to, like generation Z and Millennials.
Yeah.
Yeah,
I mean, listen, I think that we for a very,
very long time in the House, Senate in law,
at the state level, we had a lot of folks making
law related to technology who didn't totally
understand a lot of those same technologies.
There's these child porn examples from when
there were people who didn't even really
understand it making the law and then it
led to bizarre loopholes. And, you know,
it's just a kind of one little example.
I do think that as our lawmakers more and more
are the people that grew up with the technologies
that kind of governed much more of our society,
that we are going to see that taken much more
seriously. And, you know, Lindsey Graham, I
remember at one point was on the technology
committee or something with telecommunication.
I don't remember what it was. And he had never
sent an email in his life like that. Just that's
crazy. That doesn't make sense. It's a joke.
We become a joke, you know? So I think that's
certainly something that that will be different.
I also think it's going to be increasingly
a generation that it's not a generation of
socialists, but it's a generation that grew
up more open to different sort of economic
infrastructures and ideas. And I think that
that will also bring a very different approach.
I totally agree.
All right, my friend, thank you so much for the
call. Great, great question. We're taking calls
via discord at David Pakman dotcom slash discord.